Sophie, are you ready to begin?
Take me back.
Where were you before?
And before that?
You jumped.
Can you keep going?
Do you know what it feels like...
to not remember anything?
Everyone keeps telling me
who they think I am.
To fresh starts.
But if my life was so perfect,
why did I try to end it?
Sophie, it's time to move forward.
But I need to know what really happened.
We do know.
No, we think we know,
based on what we think happened.
What if I didn't jump?
Was there anything unusual about that day?
You were saying all kinds of crazy things.
A man pushed you from the boat.
Your ID said one name,
and you kept insisting
it was something else.
♪ It's the darkest hour ♪
♪ In our forest home ♪
People with perfect lives
don't usually jump off of ferries.
Day of the accident,
your husband's alibi is a lie.
If you're starting
to remember some things,
that must be really scary.
Sometimes it's hard
not knowing your own secrets.
We can't just pretend we're new people,
or that the past doesn't exist.
You really don't remember, do you?
Your husband's not who you think he is.
Why did you lie?
She's starting to
ask questions I can't answer.
Maybe I was wrong about everything.
Sophie, what's going on?
Just... putting the pieces together.
♪ It's a perfect world ♪